[MUSIC]
The idea that organizations and companies
don't handle change all that well is just
something that's really in the background
of a lot of organizational research.
Say we go to some huge
company tomorrow and
try to understand what's
keeping them from adapting.
It's very difficult, as a scientist,
to really know what's happening here and
how do I measure these different things?
And one evening I was just watching
a video game tournament, and
it just kind of hit me that everything
is observable in that world,
that things change relatively
often in that world.
When I just encountered that
eSports setting there was
just kind of a big a-ha moment.
The video game that I'm looking at is a
team video game where teams of five people
just have to play together in a really
coordinated way to win against other
teams.
You want something that has
an organizational character to it, and
that is coordinated.
So I mean, there are lots of
video games that are individual.
That wasn't really interesting to me.
The other aspect had to do with the data.
The fact that the data is
just available in that game.
Every mouse click is being recorded,
which is, if you like to play with data,
is pretty amazing.
There was also the fact that players are
playing for millions of dollars, which is
important just to make a reasonable
assumption that those people are actually
trying to win, they're actually trying
their best to be high performing.
We can be pretty confident that
whatever we're seeing here
has to do with just people trying
to coordinate with each other.
And as a scientist, being able to
isolate that, it's just pretty cool.
Organizations get faced by
change all the time and
they have new technologies
that become available.
I think very often the people who
make decision those companies
tend to think of new technologies,
new tools as a way
of improving what they're doing right now,
just doing the same thing better.
And that's pretty much the exact same
thing that I found in those video games.
What's changing in the game are the powers
of the different heroes that
they're playing.
Their first reaction would be to just do
the exact same thing, just with new tools.
They would actually explore even less
than when you didn't have change.
They wanted to relearn their current
strategy with those new tools.
Most of the teams really quickly adapt
each of the pieces, but it didn't really
think about how that enabled them
to just play differently as a team.
You could argue that it would make
sense before doing any type of change,
you would try to get the fundamentals
right trying to understand how that change
helps us do what we're
doing right now better.
What I saw in the data is that
teams on average tended to forget
about that second part, right?
They got the basics right, and then they
just stayed with the business as is.
You could make an argument that it
makes sense just because it makes you
more efficient.
What I saw in the data is that those
teams actually tended to lose more.
The teams that did adapt more were those
where everybody was communicating together
and really kind of seemed to share how
the change was affecting them personally,
so that they can kind of brainstorm
about what they could do as a team
to address that.
There's also a lot of changes
that are more indirect,
that have to do one slow component of what
you're doing changing a little bit, and
that having ripple effects on all
of the rest of what you're doing.
The winners tended to be those teams that
at least didn't seem to assume Ttat
because the change looks small,
the adaptation that we should
make will be small as well.
That sometimes you had these very with
seemingly minor changes in the code of
the game,
in the heroes that were selectable, but
they still just try to play in
a completely different way.
So in the video game world, it really
seemed like the leaders that weren't
communicating too much and
were letting their teammates participate
through decision-making were
the ones that had the most success,
were the ones most likely to look for
these new ways of working together.
Whereas the ones that the only
one speaking tended to
be in those teams where you would
see this very local reasoning.
Which suggests that really kind of
crowdsourcing some wisdom from your
employees seems to work quite well.
Now, one thing to keep in
mind is that in those teams,
the people who are the leaders
are also players, right?
So you could make an argument
that is just harder for
them to think of the big picture.
Maybe people in companies that
are managers, and it's their entire job
to be a manager, might have a better
visibility over the whole team.
But I think there is an argument to be
made for the fact that they would still
benefit from trying to understand how
their employees work together, and
actually asking them how they
think change is affecting them and
how that made impact
how they work together.
Doing the incremental
effort of thinking okay,
how does that impact the entire team, how
does it impact not just that person but
how that person can work with others,
maybe how even our unit is working with
the other units in the organization, I
think can yield a lot of payoff, actually.
One piece of the paper that should
make us hopeful is that when I was
comparing the teams at the beginning
of the observation period to
those that had gone through several
changes and had just aged over time,
the latter ones actually
seemed to do better.
Over time, it seemed like the teams that
had those sort of changes just seemed to
know that adapting system
maybe had some value.
So over time, teams just got better at
adapting, not just at the local level, but
at the system level.
Which kind of suggests that
this can be learned, right?
You're not doomed to always adapt locally.
[MUSIC]